There's many Christians out there that
say that if you just believe that Jesus
is the son of Allah Yeah. and and you
just, you know, you just believe it.
Okay. And that's it. You're good to go.
No, there's there is no there is no
honest Christian who believes in the
Bible and understands the Bible that
says, "I'm good to go." Because the same
Bible says Jesus set you free from Satan
and sin so that you sin no more but now
live in obedience to his commands.
Because Jesus said, "He who loves me
will keep my word. He who does not keep
my word does not love me." No, that's
not what the Bible teaches. That's a
lie. If there's a Christian who's that
ignorant, then he doesn't know the
Bible. That's not what the Bible
teaches. But why does God have to send
himself down to be killed to save? So
why so I said this earlier why can't he
if if he wants you to save yourself what
why can't he decree upon you more
prayers more fasting more I don't know
what you mean decree more prayers so you
can prove yourself to him what's what
has it got to do with the fact that no
matter how many good deeds you do you
still sin right you still disobey and
break his law correct it's like going to
a judge and saying hey judge look I I've
done all these good deeds but let me off
for, you know, breaking the speed limit
or for robbing that person's house. It
doesn't matter how much good deeds you
did, you still did a crime. You have a
debt, you must pay it. So, I don't
understand your logic. Where's the
logic?
Well, the logic is is that the the idea
is that the good deeds are going to
outweigh the bad or you're going to do
more good deeds than you do bad or you
should strive to do more good than bad.
And how does that undo the
Okay, let's go with this. Okay, I've
actually fed more people than houses
that I've robbed. I've only robbed 10
houses, but I fed a thousand people. How
does me feeding a thousand people undo
the damage of breaking into people's
homes and robbing their
merchandise? How does that undo that?
How does one undo the other?
So I've carjacked.
If you if you have stopped it, you have
done it and you have stopped and then
Okay, I stopped it. Okay. Oh, let me go
with you. Okay. I already broke into 10
homes and I stole 20 cars and I stopped.
But I still broke into 20 10 homes and
stole 20 cars. I already did the damage.
I already did the crime. Now, who pays
for
that? I stopped, but I still did it. Who
pays for that?
You.
It's already been done. Okay, your
honor. I stop. I don't break into homes
anymore. Even though I broke into 10
homes. I don't steal cars anymore. Even
though I've already stolen 20 cars.
That's my past. But hold on, sir. But
everybody's going to stand. Yeah.
Exactly. Islam. Exactly. 100%. So
there's still a debt that needs to be
paid. So the Lord Jesus in his mercy
paid that debt so now you can be
forgiven.
But the Jews don't believe that. Which
Jews? You mean the thousands of Jews
that are Christians like Michael Brown
that do believe that? Which Jews you
talking about? You keep thinking all
Jews believe the same thing. It's like
saying all the Muslims believe in
Bkari. Do all Muslims? No. You have
Shiau. You have Quran only Muslims. You
have Alawi. I mean, which Jews? What are
you talking about?
The mainstream Jews. Extreme Jews. The
same Jews that don't believe Jesus is
born of a virgin. Don't believe Jesus is
the Messiah.
Main main mainstream Jews. The
mainstream Jews that don't believe in
Jesus, that don't believe he's the
Messiah, don't believe he's born of the
virgin, that he's a false messiah, a
cursed by God. So, let's go follow them.
Let's reject Christianity in Islam.
I didn't say but I mean they they get
into heaven according to them by deeds
and you get into heaven according to you
by deeds right but you're both wrong
aren't you?
So who cares what they think? Be wrong
and you are right. If you have two out
of three that are consistent with each
other, why can't you re-evaluate what
you think? Because when I go when I go
to their ideology is not consistent with
the two other Abrahamic faith. Why?
Because when I go Well, I'm answering
you. So you're asking but you're not
letting me answer. Because when I go to
their Tanakh Hebrew Bible, I see they're
wrong. Because I asked the Jew, if it's
your good deeds that brings you into
right relationship, then why in the
world did you have a temple, a
sacrificial system, and priests that had
to offer sacrifices daily and once a
year for all your sins to be forgiven so
you wouldn't come under God's wrath? Can
you explain Leviticus 16 for me? Yam
kipur. Yam kipurum, the day of
atonements. Can you explain Leviticus
17:10-14 for me? Without the remission
of sins, there is no forgiveness where
it says that the blood makes atonement
by virtue of the of its life. So they
slaughtered the animals, didn't they?
Why? If only my good deeds are all I
need to be in right relation with God,
why then waste all these animals and
shed all the blood of millions of
animals. If you count from the time of
Moses to Jesus, God knows how many
thousands if not millions of animals
blood was shed. It was a bloody mess in
the temple.
Yes, Sam. Let me let me explain. S Sam,
uh, where are you from? I'm Assyrian.
Ashuri from Kuwait. Born in Kuwait, but
my parents are from Iraq. What about it?
We're changing subjects now. What about
Ashi? Not Arab man. Assyan were before
you. We're your daddies.
Anyway, okay. I'm just asking you. Yeah.
Uh,
so what the Jews
did, they gave atonement. Are you with
me so far? Yeah. Why? Why?
So, not only is it good deeds, but you
see those animals, they were they were
assets to the Jews because why? They why
shed their blood? You're not answering
the questions yet. Why shed their blood?
They are giving up something of value to
them. So, because those animals are a
source of their livelihood. Okay. So,
why do I need to give up a life of an
animal? Is that what it said? said, "No,
the animal dies in your place because
the blood makes atonement." Because the
animal's dying so that you can be
spared. That's what Leviticus 17:11
says. Why are you reinterpreting what
Leviticus 17:11 says?
You're telling me, they sacrifice those.
Huh? You're telling me one thing and
their book tells me another thing.
Leviticus 17:11, it says that the life
is in the blood and I've given you the
blood to make atonement for life. It's
the blood that makes atonement for the
life, the soul. It's not you're giving
up something of monetary value. No,
you're giving up an animal who has to
die in your place so that you don't die
even though you deserve to. So the
animal dies in your place so you can be
spared from death. That's what it says.
Leviticus 17:11. So Jesus practiced
this. No, Jesus is telling you those
animal practices were pointing to me.
Why do you think God told them to
sacrifice animals? Because that's a
picture of me, the lamb of God, because
I will do once and for all what all
those animals could not do for you. But
they were pointing to me.
But how does that make sense to you?
Very easy. It makes sense. Can I explain
to you how it makes sense?
Go ahead. Okay. The Bible talks about
sin. The word sin. I thought it was
about giving up something of value. No,
that's not what Leviticus 17 says.
Leviticus 16 and 17 didn't say that. But
about how you interpret it. Okay. Okay.
Let's try this again. Interpret for me.
I'm going to read it for you now. I want
to see how many ways you're going to
spin Leviticus 17:11. Let me read it for
you. Okay. For the life, let me read it
for you before you hold on. Let me read
it and explain. For the life, the soul
of the flesh is in the blood. I have
given it to you upon the altar to make
atonement for your souls. For it is the
blood that makes an atonement for the
soul. Can explain that atonement.
Read it again. Oh, sorry. For the life
of the flesh, the soul, the nefs of the
flesh, is in the blood. And I've given
it to you upon the altar to make an
atonement for your souls. For it is the
blood that makes atonement for the soul.
The blood.
Yes. When you kill an animal, you shed
its blood and the blood is brought
before the altar as a sign. An animal
has died in order to make atonement for
this human soul.
So why are you So it doesn't have Go
ahead. It doesn't It doesn't have
nothing to do with giving something up.
Yeah. You're giving up the life of an
animal to spare your life. The life of
an animal for my life or I have to die.
That's the principle.
So why is God going to accept an animal
instead of you? Because do you want to
die? Okay, you can die and go to hell
because God is showing you mercy. If I
demand you die, you go to hell. But in
my mercy, I'll let someone die in your
place so I can spare you. So, okay,
sure. Tell God, "Hey, God, forget the
animal. Take me." All right then,
Yousef, I'll take you right straight to
hell. All right, good deal.
So that's what you want? No, God, I
don't understand. I don't understand
that logic because let me tell you the
logic. I was trying to explain it to
you. That's it.
Okay. Sin sin is breaking God's command.
When you break God's command, it says
you shall die. The soul that sin shall
die. So if I break his command, my
punishment is death. So what's the
payment for sin? Death. What's the debt?
Death. So God says either you pay that
debt and you die or someone can pay the
debt for you. So what Jesus did is said
I will pay the debt of your sin. I will
take your place in death so you can be
spared because now your debt is
paid. That's the logic.